[Music]
reuben is with us in green bay wisconsin
hi reuben welcome to the ramsay show
hi mr ramsey how are you doing today
better than i deserve sir how can i help
fantastic uh so
yeah first my question and uh and i'll
fill in a couple blanks uh i am getting
ready to uh go into a new field um
it's life insurance i'm getting ready to
take my state exam i've been studying
for the last
month
and this is final expense insurance and
i recently heard on one of your shows
you kind of had spoken against whole
life insurance this is really
a brand new
landscape for me so i really don't have
a lot of frame of reference i guess i
just want to make sure
i'm um
getting into something that's
you know
noteworthy and you know going to uh to
be something i can stand behind
the insurance company i'm getting ready
to pair with is called lincoln heritage
so um
that is uh that's kind of what's going
on currently just a little background
like on a personal
um
44 just turned 44.
i am on my
just over two years clean from a 20-year
heroin addiction wow definitely
definitely a late bloomer here um
i had a dependency issue with chemicals
for a long time uh
jail's institution and then finally
death
i was revived i ended up going into a
faith-based
recovery program and
he got healed set free
and uh jesus is my lord and savior thank
you lord second second chance in life i
really feel and i just wanna
you know i'm trying to um
this it's more than just about money to
me it's about
breaking generational things i've got
children i just have
so much uh to be thankful for so much
riding on
on all of this um i have a great church
i've been plugged into and uh
they um they were the ones that first
you know exposed me to
your podcast and to baby steps um
actually i lost my uh my job
right before christmas um what were you
doing and
i was actually selling for uh budget
blinds um
so you're you're a people person
i love yeah i love it
you know obviously
yeah going into people's house and just
kind of connecting with them sometimes i
really felt like the secondary reason i
was there is to help them with window
treatments or whatever but
yeah it was definitely fulfilling and
you're a hero reuben man i'm proud of
you way to go um so let's do it let's do
a couple of things um
th this is a decision you have to make
you don't make it because i said to
you've got to gather facts but you're
calling me and saying
uh it bothered you that i tell people
not to buy whole life and you're signed
up to become a salesman for it so that's
throwing you off
um well i guess it's industrial life
right because it's final expense
insurance so i don't know if it's one in
the same i have no idea
i mean i do have an idea in that i'm
studying i understand the whole life is
different than industrial and so uh you
know that's the
insurance that you're selling have a
cash value
uh it does okay then it's a type of
whole life or cash value product there
there are various types i mean there's
uh universal life there's variable life
there's a whole lot there's industrial i
mean but anything that has a cash value
in it is where i'm gonna have a problem
okay
okay um and i i'm not gonna end this
call
i i think you're an amazing man and i
don't want to end this call trash your
dreams of
what you're going for for your career
but i'm going to give you a whole bunch
of stuff to work on and decide for
yourself number one i'm going to give
you a copy of ken coleman's new book
from paycheck to purpose
because that's the move you're trying to
make you're trying to get into something
that has meaning and purpose because
your life has a
a whole fresh start you're seeing things
with cleaner eyes than you have ever
seen because of your journey and it's a
wonderful place in your journey that you
are and we want to assist you in that
and uh so that that book is in case i
talk you into quitting before you start
okay okay uh so the the product
the reason i don't like the product is
this
the way it works
mathematically
is not a good deal for the person that
buys it
and i'll explain it to you okay
whole life traditional cash value
insurance
is
20 times
more expensive for the same amount
of coverage of life insurance
and so
let's say you were going to buy a
a
a
200 000 policy if it was a hundred
dollars a month for whole life
it would be five dollars a month for
term insurance
right okay
now
where does the other 95 go well it goes
to build up this cash
value
inside the policy it's a savings account
inside the policy in and of itself
that's not a bad problem except that the
fees are ridiculous in the whole life
world now i don't know the particular
product you're selling but the
typical whole life policy the first
three years your cash value buildup is
zero
which means they kept your ninety five
dollars a month that you put in a
savings account it was zero
upfront fees
okay
the second thing is the rate at which
the money accrues is somewhere around
1.2
according to federal trade commission
studies the rate of return on your
savings account sucks
as a long-term investment and this is a
long-term play
and the third problem is this
when you die after paying 95
extra per month five dollars bought the
insurance
and you're paying 95 extra for savings
they pay
the face value of the policy in this
case two hundred thousand dollars
so if you've built up after you got
through the three zero years and you got
a horrible rate of return and you keep
putting 95 in there and you built up 20
000 in cash value and you die they send
your beneficiary your spouse probably
200 000 bucks what happens to your
thousand dollar savings account that
sucked they keep it
and so this is like going down to the
bank and opening a savings account that
the first three years you put money in
it they keep your money after that they
give you a lousy rate of return and when
you when you die they keep your money
it's a horrible way to save money
and so consequently the people that
you're talking about going to work for
hate me
with a vengeance because i tell people
not to buy what they sell every day and
have for 30 years um the worst the the
particular product that you're in or
that company i'm not even familiar with
but i'll guarantee you that their face
is going to turn inside out and explode
when you just mention the name dave
ramsey so don't mention it because it
won't do any good we don't want
anybody's head exploding i'm not going
to make friends like that yeah it's not
if you're going to quit just quit be do
it with class you don't have to go in
there and try to change them you're not
going to change them they're going to
keep doing it they've been doing it for
100 years
so
lastly what i'll do so that you can
review this material
in detail is i want to sign you up for
ramsey plus which is the financial peace
university class and every dollar app
in that class there is an insurance
lesson that goes into detail
on the life insurance portion so you can
learn in detail what we teach about life
insurance and i you can't dispute it
because it's just math it's a fact
and so
consequently
no financial planning people unless
they're in the insurance business and
call themselves financial planners no
one in the financial world pushes cash
value life insurance anywhere unless
they sell it
there's no independent financial people
that push the stuff they all say buy the
term insurance for five dollars instead
of the cash value for 100 do your
investing with your 95 difference
anywhere else but inside of a cash value
policy you're better off putting it in a
fruit jar in the backyard at least the
family can find it and it's there when
you die they don't keep it yeah it's
trying to be investing in insurance at
the same time and it's it's terrible at
both at the end of the day so if i'm
selling this thing i'm going to have a
moral problem knowing how much i know so
he's ignorance was bliss until now
reuben just learned a little too much
about whole life i think he can find a
better job out there if he loves sales
if he even loves insurance that's a
noble thing to sell but not whole life i
would stay away and these companies are
like a northwestern you know it's your
buddies from college that want to make a
big commission off you yeah stay away
yeah it's uh
again i
i tell you never to buy it and so and i
know i'm kind of bursting your bubble in
the middle of you having this whole
recovery journey and everything and i i
don't want to do that i want to say
you're a hero i'm proud of you you and i
are going to be friends even if you
decide to work there so i'm just you
stay with it buddy but um
hang on kelly i'll get you the book for
ken coleman and we'll get you signed up
for ramsey plus i'm not charging you a
thing for any of this and i'm not going
to keep your money when you die